we've shown you what wealth inequality
looks like in terms of pie you want to
see what it looks like in terms of real
money yeah okay give a penny
not on my purse don't be okay I've got a
penny that penny in the typical
Americans household is worth the same
amount in Jeff Bezos his pocket as that
for every penny that the typical
American has he's got this eleven
thousand seven hundred dollars wow
that's that's insane I'm sure you found
a penny when you do laundry or something
in it like take it out of your pants
before goes in the dryer or you hear it
rattling around the dryer and then I key
or I keep it you know if it's someone
else's penny my kids pennies the typical
family to find a penny in the dryer
that's like Jeff Bezos the richest man
in America
finding eleven thousand seven hundred
dollars
oh my god for every penny of wealth in
the middle of the country
he has eleven thousand seven hundred
dollars in wealth that's really
upsetting that is extremely upsetting
that's kind of shocking it's shocking
right can even pick up a penny but if
this is what it was to somebody else you
know what I mean like sometimes you walk
by a penny and you don't even care to
pick it up but you notice that I saw
this if you fact if you heard this
rattling around in the dryer and you're
like what's that noise you take the
penny out this would be pretty
surprising Oh
you